[Music]
people tell me that New York can be the
best place in the world in most social
place in the world but it can also be
the loneliest place in the world as well
the goal this supper club is to bring
people together
[Music]
my name is Vincent Wu and I am known for
running a supper club called mr. Jones
supper club yeah I'm a guy with scallops
in the basement of my apartment chives
and a small basket of the shallots it
started when I got here about three
years ago I didn't know anyone and I
miss getting together around the kitchen
with friends eating and so I started
with acquaintances and then one thing
led to another and it sort of blew up I
only do it two times a month but the
demand is over two three years now and
that's that's rounding down guests do
not have to pay to come you pay whatever
you feel like at the end of the night
based on how much they enjoy the
experience and how much they they can
afford
I'm not formally trained in cooking with
say YouTube it's probably my teacher
every month and mr. Jones has no menus
ever the same last Saturday we started
off with some burrata and then it was
accompanied by two nut citta and topped
with fried lotus root chips then we had
scallop crudo it was a hell of agent
flavors as well then we had the mushroom
on mushroom on mushroom which is like
big chunky maitake mushroom baked in the
oven I love doing this I definitely have
made friends from it people have
definitely made friends with with each
other from it as well my first time like
you know finding long-lost people
together I think it's a good way just to
stop and get people to be present
sometimes with people without phones and
just just talk and get to know someone
you